au labrador quand un enfant est retiré
de sa famille il est souvent envoyé très
loin de chez lui dans une famille
d'accueil
de la caa fin du prêt ses trois bambins
nous devons protéger leur identité livre
maintenant à plus de mille kilomètres de
chez eux
cette femme qui les hébergent touche
mensuellement 900 $ par enfant
alors qu'on est peu les parents
autochtones ce déséquilibre est au coeur
du problème
elle me la ministre qui donne de
l'agencé on enlève des enfants de leur
famille mais on ne donne pas assez de la
jambe pour la prévention pour soutenir
les familles les paroles pour un enfant
autochtone c'est nécessairement un
déracinement une perte de sa langue
c'est certain que si et placé pendant
les années il va perdre sa langue va
parle de ses racines culturelles
on perpétue le traumatisme du
déracinement quand on retire une enfant
autochtone de sa famille on le fait pour
le protéger mais les analyses des
risques seraient parfois abusive des
fois les intervenants semblent vouloir
sans nécessairement être assises vont
avoir des préjugés ou des biens
culturels qui va faire en sorte qu'on va
plus ou moins bien évalués ou peut-être
procéder à un retrait des enfants au
canada les enfants autochtones
représentent 7 7% de la population mais
ils sont 52% des enfants placés en
familles d'accueil beaucoup
d'autochtones comparses traumatisme à
celui du pensionnat
la ministre est d'accord on a une crise
une crise ça donne un impact
psychologique pour peut-être toute la
vie de cet enfant et pour la famille
cette nuit du labrador voit sa fille
pour la première fois depuis trois ans
j'aimerais qu'on soit réuni dit elle
maintenant sobre elle a récupéré ses
autres enfants
mais à voir sa fille sera difficile la
protection de la jeunesse juge souvent
qu'un enfant placé depuis de nombreuses
années et mieux en famille d'accueil
la loi de la protection de la jeunesse
elle est complètement inadéquate répond
pas aux besoins et aux réalités des
familles autochtones et non seulement à
leur manière d'éduquer au fondement de
la famille aux stratégies éducatives des
il faut changer le système pour que les
enfants puissent être avec leur famille
le ministre demande aux provinces de
mieux s'adapter aux réalités autochtones
de son côté ottawa promet plus d'argent
pour aider les familles à traiter les
problèmes l'alcoolisme par exemple qui
entraîne tant de déracinement pour
éviter qu'une autre génération passe sa
vie à soigner le traumatisme d'une
enfance brisée ici sophie langlois radio
canada montréal